was there a moment when you were there
on that day may may 31st 1986 where you
were asked to leave or people started to
get suspicious because if you were to do
that nowadays people would ask you do
you have a permit what are you doing i
mean especially with that size camera
no it's a good question we didn't have
any hostility we didn't have we weren't
asked to leave
security had much
more important issues at the time which
was you know
underage drinking maybe and just uh kind
of monitoring the crowd control we
didn't get in the way you know we
weren't going up to
we didn't create any scene i think had
we done something like that we might
have called more attention to ourselves
and that's something we were very
mindful of because we didn't even know
if we would when we went in if we would
encounter any hostility from
you know security or from the the people
that were were there we didn't know if
uh you know any anybody would be
take offense to being taped but uh we
didn't encounter any of that and i think
you're right though a lot of it was the
novelty of the time and you know
nowadays everything's taped
you can't go anywhere without something
being recorded um
and so to have cameras or you know a
video camera in an environment like that
in 1986 and these cameras look like news
crew cameras you know it wasn't i mean
home video was out but that was still
very much a novelty and you didn't not
very many people had camcorders
so we were um
we were kind of a welcome
if site if not a real curiosity i mean
people were very forthcoming
a couple people were you know you know
you know
mouthed off to us but it was all in good
good fun
and uh
and we just we just kind of rolled with
it
did that day
teach you anything about like
spontaneity versus over planning
um well definitely it was uh a lot of uh
we we just
it's always kind of been our hallmark
john and i have collaborated on other
projects and i've always
enjoyed doing the this uh filmmaking
without a great deal of
certainly verite cam you know
documentary you can't really plan for it
um
and you just want it to unfold you don't
want to
script it you don't want to put words in
anybody's mouths and you don't want to
fake it and
you know i mean there is you know
filmmaking that isn't that is
agenda-oriented or or trying to go for
you know comic relief or what have you
or or
you know with a real goal and that's
fine i mean that's certainly there's
nothing wrong with that i i we
at the time didn't have an agenda go in
there other filmmaking i've done along
these lines
it's just kind of fun to go and see what
happens let it unfold um but i've done
enough stuff to know that
if you have something in mind then and
something you want to achieve
the more pre-production the better
and uh
but when we did that particular
documentary i think not having any
pre-production or not having any agent
you know shooting script or any kind of
plan
worked in our favor
so
i think there's something to be said for
both
you